it's early morning in kiev but there's
already a queue at the passport office
waiting for travel documents anyone who
wants to travel to the eu without a visa
will need a biometric passport olga
antonienko has been here since seven
o'clock
where do i want to go oh i've got lots
of plans my daughter might be going to
belgium next year to study and i'd like
to visit her
negotiations have taken years the eu had
reservations and there were security
concerns but in strasbourg in mid-may
the last signature was finally put in
place and president petro poroshenko
could celebrate
but not all ukrainians will be able to
take advantage of this new freedom of
movement
there are some problems with issuing
travel documents especially biometric
passports to the 1.7 million internally
displaced people and the people living
in the occupied zones
the eu views this with some concern
their ambassador in kiev wants all
agreements connected with the visa
liberalization to be correctly fulfilled
this will not be an easy task because in
some areas like
the fight against corruption the rule of
law we know that there are a number of
people in ukraine who are trying their
best to backtrack on what has been
achieved and therefore it will be
necessary for the ukrainian authorities
to be extremely vigilant
but there are other problems on olga
antonienko's mind the new regulations
mean she has to carry 45 euros cash for
every day she plans to spend in the eu
that's a lot of money for a teacher
earning 300 euro a month
after eight hours waiting she's finally
able to lodge her application in three
weeks her new passport will be ready
we've waited a long time for this
finally ukrainians are able to travel
out of the country
the ukrainian foreign ministry also has
reason to celebrate in its soviet era
headquarters the new visa regime was
negotiated between here and brussels as
part of a much broader agreement to ease
trade barriers now that too can come
into force
you